how's it going guys Matt here from code
Tech tutorials we're going to look at
the controller design pattern this is a
behavioral design that you can add to
your code
and you will see kind of how it goes
this is often called a mediator or an
intermediary or something like that but
basically it's where you have a bunch of
components talk back to a main
controller the main controller does some
work as needed and updates other
components and and stuff like that so
the traditional example here is like an
airplane and the air traffic controller
where all the airplanes all they do is
send their data to their traffic
controller which would be like you know
a position when they're going to land
that sort of stuff and they're a traffic
controller controls or sends data back
to the other planes as needed so sort of
that kind of setup I'm going to show you
how to do that in C plus plus code so
let's just dive right into it I already
recorded this episode once and I
realized at the end when I went to uh
start editing it that my mic was not set
correctly so yeah I just literally
talked
blankly into my screen for like an hour
and here we are doing it again doing it
for you guys hope you appreciate it all
right so let's start out
uh with some base requirements here uh
we're going to have well
yeah we're gonna have an interface of a
controller uh sometimes you call it you
know you can call it different things
I'm going to be calling the whole
mediator thing a controller in this case
and I'm just going to be calling the
things we're working on components but
those are generally whatever you know
something and whatever you're working on
all right so first of all we're just
going to forward declare a base
component because we're going to be
working with those here so then we're
going to make a controller and
just put some some basic stuff in here
this is going to be an interface class
here maybe I'll put eye controller yeah
let's do I or interface and it's going
to have a virtual avoid a notify method
and this will take a base component
pointer and we'll call it sender in this
case and then we need some sort of event
now if we're talking about airplanes the
event might be movement or I don't know
it could be anything I imagine you
probably do an event every radar tick or
something on that case but in our case
we're just going to make it so that we
can console out a string so in our case
our event is just going to be a string
which works and equals zero so that
makes it an interface and there we go
all right so now we need to Define what
this base component is here let's go
ahead and do that base
component and you'll see why we had the
board declare it because if we try to
declare this above the controller we're
going to have a problem right here at
this part where we go
we want to reference to a controller it
wouldn't know what it is yet unless we
for declared controller for yeah so
that's why we got to do that forward
declare right there
controller there we go
and then let's just make some uh some
base stuff here let's make a Constructor
that takes a controller interface
pointer
um let's move let's put this one Member
One with an underscore in front of it
now if you don't pass a controller here
it's just going to be no pointer but if
you do
then we'll set it up
just like so all right and then nothing
in the body there so default construct
as null pointer
or if you actually pass it one it'll set
it up right away so we'll have a little
bit of options there all right and then
we'll have a set method here set
controller
and all this is going to do is also take
a same thing
this time no null pointer default there
because you actually need one and it's
going to kind of do what you would
expect controller equals whatever you
pass in that way you can kind of set
them up on the fly or change them if you
want maybe you want to change to a
different traffic controller or
something you could do that on the
components via this method or you can
even have it well you'll see here I
think it's pretty neat because you can
even have the controller itself call
this and change it to different ones if
you want but we'll be using that here
shortly
all right so now let's go ahead and make
some components we got a base component
uh we don't really want to instantiate
this one because it well it's got some
nice defaults we want the set controller
but also we want our components to
actually do something so let's make them
we'll make component one
inherit this base component and
see
you know it's already going to have all
this stuff so that's already going to be
in there but we want it to do whatever
it does so we just need to decide in our
case uh you know just an example you
sure we could work it up with airplanes
and pass in positions and do that sort
of example and that's fine if you want
to do that as practice awesome but I'm
just going to give you a very generic
example so we're just going to do we're
gonna do something you know this would
be essentially the component doing
something maybe it's flying forward for
example like or takeoff or Landing or
you know it could be anything like that
it would essentially when you call these
these methods this is when you call a
notify back to the controller which
would be this method here in the center
right there all right so let's just say
um
I don't know I mean we can really put
anything we're just kind of spitballing
here we're just going to say uh fly all
right fly is fine maybe component one
actually is a play I don't know I'm
gonna put a little C out here
um and just say just so we can see in
the console component one uh lies proper
plural there
wait is that proper she so bad in
English is it is it like that in this
case because it's not actually plural
it's it's
I'm going to call it something else just
because I don't even know all right well
maybe we'll just make it a little let's
just worked differently for my own sake
opponent one flies forward
there we go let's just word it like that
opponent one is flying forward all right
so hey what do we want to do this we
want to notify our controller of this
case so what we do is we call this
notify method so we call
uh let's see
so we've already we should have a
reference to this controller we can just
call it we can just go like so and just
notify and we want to pass it of course
a sender which is itself so that way it
knows about uh this whole thing here and
then we want the event so we'll just
save flying forward that's fine enough
you know in theory you can say whatever
you want uh you know depends on your
events your particular thing let's go
ahead and get our included straightened
out where we're at include string
include i o stream and just solve those
right there all right so there we go
we've got a method right there let's do
uh lands or Landing and essentially
going to be the same thing we'll just uh
this in here I'm gonna put I'm just
going to change this to a simple single
word here opponent one is
Landing
and land okay so that way we can kind of
notify of the event notify four notify
land a bit generic and simple but uh you
know I'm kind of keeping with the
example of the airplane at least a
little bit but really these could be
anything depending on what you're doing
and if you're in a game it could be like
I don't know what if your component
let's say you have a component of
weather and you decide it's going to
start storming
so you would call a storm then you would
notify the controller of storm and then
that would notify other things like
maybe other components happen to be
players or something and they would
start getting wet or something or
getting cold if you're in a survival
game so it can you know it can
essentially do all kinds of stuff
eventually and we'll we'll get to that
we'll get a little further let's make
another component here for another
example I'm going to actually name this
component uh plane component there that
way it uh you know sticks on theme
airplane component see there we go cool
sounds good and maybe we have another
one yeah sure let's do it let's do a
weather one let's do a weather component
since we're doing examples I just want
to give you the idea that these can you
know be anything that might have events
and we'll see how that works with the
controller slash mediator very soon so
we'll say storming or raining I'll just
say raining
um
and I'll change these here to airplane
airplanes flying forward okay opinions
landing and you know you might have a
bunch of others like take off stuff and
I'm going to skip all that it's we could
go on forever if we go into that kind of
detail we'll say here weather
maybe I should put the word component on
these I don't know it doesn't matter as
long as it's clear in the console yeah
you'll probably get the point here
weather component begins rain sure and
then we just take the controller notify
that the weather component says rain
and you know we could do that with this
one maybe we'll say sunshine in this
case you could you know we'll get to
this later uh we'll just say sun in Sun
all right well that works for now those
are a little a couple sample ones we can
work with here so now let's go to the
controller this is where things get fun
and interesting so we're going to take
and uh just and make an actual in a
concrete interface so class we'll we'll
just call this uh
let's call it concrete controller I
guess for now I can't think of a better
name but it is some kind of controller I
guess it maybe it's maybe it is an air
travel it doesn't matter I guess so
we're gonna inherit from our eye
controller our interface here and of
course we're gonna need some stuff so
this does need to know in one way or
another about the components so let's go
ahead and put those in here and
airplane comp that and then we want the
weather one it's called weather comp
sounds good
if you have more than one you could make
these Dynamic arrays or something if you
got a bunch of airplanes or you know
stuff like that or weathers for
different areas you could get very
complicated with this actually that is
one of the drawbacks of this controller
uh method is eventually your controller
can become huge in a mess and control
everything and it's just like a giant
giant block of code
um that's that's that's one of the
drawbacks but it's got some nice
advantages of uh how it you can talk to
components and stuff this way so that's
where it is cool all right so let's go
ahead and make a Constructor here
uh oops and we want to take in some
references to these to to get everything
initialized let's copy this down
actually we'll give them different names
of course here in a second for the ones
being passed in call this one AC this
one WC sounds good to me and we can just
instantiate those directly here
and then
now this is where things get a little
interesting so okay so you set the
components but now how do the components
know about the controller well we have
this very cool and all the components
the set controller method so we just
call that from these ones that we passed
in so we take this we go set controller
and pass it this which is the this
controller here the one we're building
so it makes it very easy to do that sort
of thing
it just feels good to code this all
right so let's set up the notify so what
happens uh when these methods are called
and they end up calling the notify let's
build the notify now this is something
that they know about because it's the
interface up here and uh yeah they
should have it set up now based on this
Constructor okay so let's set this up we
gotta override it
and
this is where we do the work essentially
processing the event sometimes based on
the sender uh it just it really this is
where the monolithic part can really
start especially once you get a bunch of
different components and stuff this can
be a lot of a lot of logic but we're
going to keep it really simple for now
let's just say okay we got events we
know we got events there's strings so so
we can just do kind of an if else well
just ifs I guess so we can say if event
equals equals we know some of the
possible options forward land rain Sun
um and uh we know this we should know a
little about the sender but really all
we know is that it is a base component
at this point we would have to try to
dynamically cast it so weather or
airplane or some component to see if
it's that and I'll see if those casts
fail or not typically though you want to
avoid Dynamic casts and code just
because they're slow but you know if in
a pinch you can't do it we're going to
kind of skip that for now but the main
thing is you want to be able to uh do
some callbacks basically
all right so let's say if the event is
Sun for example then we want to know
that I don't know we would do something
let's just uh let's make a c out right
at the top just to show what event we we
got in
received here
so event uh received and then we'll just
kind of put out what it is here
it's a string it works nice in the
console here now I guess the event word
is a keyword I don't know
all right so we can at least get that
data in the console to know that we
actually received the event um but then
you know based on what event you got and
maybe based on your testing of different
Dynamic casts you can see what sent and
what it sent and do all sorts of
processing we're going to kind of ignore
this first thing for the for now just to
keep it a little simplified but uh you
know if we get sun for example maybe we
call comp2 here or
to airplane comp and we say
oh that there's Sun we can land
and that'll call this one here and that
will then notify the controller of land
so we would call this it would do its
thing and the component would do its
thing and if it needs to it would
re-notify of Landing but maybe there's
more complicated logic in this Landing
uh it's just just an example but uh for
example if we now have another event of
the landing
where was it planned let's just land
okay and we could say I don't know I'll
just put some words here airplane is
landing
and if we need to notify any other
specific components we could I can't
imagine how you would need to notify or
do specific things to the web you don't
necessarily have control of the weather
so maybe this weather part is a bad
example it might be better as just
airplane 2 and we could probably work a
little better with that because then we
could say
um don't land airplane two one's already
Landing but uh you get the point here
I'm gonna kind of uh just leave it at
that I think and we'll make some calls
to this and you can see it work but you
can you can see how you can kind of
expand on this and get all sorts of
logic going on between your different
components and uh you know the main
thing is you get this controller going
and as you your components notify the
controller the controller can do
whatever it needs to I can imagine this
would be pretty good for like game
server stuff too as different uh
different people connected to your
server notify the server of different
things happening you might need to do
other stuff in your world or put items
on the ground or whatever it may be so a
very cool pattern all right let's go
ahead and make it just a main down here
and let's go ahead and work with a
little bit make a quick example so of
course we need our components let's make
our airplane component
um
it's called airplane I guess and we'll
just make a new airplane and we'll do
one for the weather as well and then of
course we need our controller make sure
I actually get this
there we go and now we need our
controller which we've just called
concrete controller and the way we've
set it up we just need to pass in these
two components airplane and weather
there we go since they're already
pointers they should just pass right in
get all set up and then as it calls this
Constructor it should set the
controllers up on those components so
very nice there
and then we can start calling stuff so
nothing will actually happen until we
call a method like we'll call Airplane
let's call one that we know actually
does something airplane landing
so we get we know that when we call
airplane landing it's gonna notify the
controller of land uh which is going to
go down here to land and say airplane is
landing skip over the Sun and uh maybe
we can also call another one just for
say for example it's kind of a weird
example but hopefully gets the point
across for you guys uh maybe we call
rainy all right let's call it sunshine
first now Sunshine we don't have a
statement for that to process it so all
we should see is event received Sunshine
so that's fine sure we could do our I
was talking about earlier we could put
more info in here and you know test what
components sent via Dynamic cast based
on all the possible components Etc et
cetera
but you know and that might be fine but
if you do that a ton we get some clunky
code but at least you could do cool
stuff there the options there at least
it's better to have the option and for
it to be slow than to just not have the
option at all I guess but I love Dynamic
cast I play around with him a lot but be
careful about overusing them all right
then that's called weather raining so
when we call the sun one we should get
Landing again so we should get landing
and we should get sun and Landing again
and then raining that's what we should
see based on this based on how it's
going to Cascade oh maybe we'll just
throw one more thing in here at the end
like this fly forward uh just for the
heck of it airplane fly forward
all right and now it is also assumed oh
we're going to make this right
controller helps to uh create your
variables correctly
since these are all pointers and as you
can see
uh the concrete controller here sure has
pointer axis but it doesn't ever delete
the pointers which means it does not own
the pointers it's assumed that the
client is going to manage their own
stuff here so basically what that means
is when we're all done here we've got to
be sure we delete them since there we do
own them here in this main client code I
gotta be sure to clean up after
ourselves sure we can just make them
unique pointers but that's
gonna turn into a mess of other codes
for me it's just it's just more simple
to do this real quick uh
all right so let's go ahead and give
this a run hit the play button here
looks like we have some code errors
somewhere I've probably just forgot
semicolons at the end of these classes I
tend to do that just one there it looks
like
oh I forgot to put the word concrete
controller here again that will cause an
error and some little mistakes looks
like we got it all sorted out and as
expected it did what we thought first
thing we called was landing and uh
component set it then the event received
land airplanes landing um then we said
Sun Sun received and we had that call we
had the sun call Landing so naturally
called it again because that's how we
made it not that it makes any logical
sense but you know Sunshine is great for
landing probably better than rain and we
got the airplanes landing and then we
called the rain one which is right here
and event received rain that's all that
one does uh fly forward and receive
forward so yeah looks like it's working
pretty good but hopefully you understand
this pattern and it works well for you
super cool pattern uh I love it and uh
something that I will probably use a lot
going forward I've used it something
like it a little bit but now that I've
studied this pattern a little more oh I
I'm really glad I did hope you feel the
same all right I'll see you guys in the
next video thanks for watching mad out
peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign